[Applaus] so bitte erschreckt mich ich spiele
jetzt wieder eine Rolle aber denkt immer dran
ich bin es eure Anna ich bin gar nicht so böse und
weg Kameraden gern fremdung ist auf dem Vormarsch
wir müssen die letzten Instanzen der Ordnung
verteidigen das Netz ist nicht sicher NSA die
überprüfen alles wie aber Kameraden können wir
da noch unerkannt kommunizieren wir müssen uns
tarnen wir brauchen einen Code um uns weiter
gegen Entartung und Entfremdung zu formieren
Schlager Geheimsprache vor sehr gut
Kamera aber wie soll das vonstatten gehen
wir schreiben nicht Hitler sondern hielter
wir schreiben nicht Kamerad sondern Kram aber
wir schreiben nicht Fackelzug sondern zu gewackt
wir schreiben nicht Ehre sondern Kerze das
liegt nah aber wir fallen nicht ins Raster
statt Tradition Erhalt der Rasse schreiben
wir gerade dazu und Erkältung der blassen
Hilter Erkältung der blassen
steckt gravitationen krameraden
fantastisch weiter so statt Vaterland wadenbrand
statt Führer Schreber statt wer macht wer lacht
stattfeind Kleid statt Wotan als von so
statt Odin Muckefuck statt Kot Schlot statt
Kampf Krampf statt Kommunist Kuckuck pisst
statt Sieg schrunsenflug Stadtverteidigung
das Geschmeidigkeit statt Angst Märzenbecher
statt Entartung Renate Entfremdung entenhemd
statt Heimat Dreirad statt Bomben Holocaust
Plomben Wut Applaus statt volkser tüchtigungen
das muss das Kleid erstmal wütend
machen wenn wir das Enten Hemd mit
hochwertig bestücken keiner soll uns den
wadenbrand im Krampf schützenflogen das
Schutz und Fluch ist unsicher
unserer Heirat ist das meine
Zukunft
ja Kramer baden
[Applaus]
Renate Becher auf dem Dreirad
das Kleid bedeckt von muckefuckt
unser Dreirad und unser warten Brandt
schrunsenflug schrunsenflug schwanten
fantastisch krameradender so
schlagen wir dem Skat ein schräppchen
niemals obersturmbandführer und Öffentlichkeit
Verzeihung hobelwurm stand Syrer
schon besser sonst noch etwas
Anna Blume geliebte meiner 27 sind es das etwas
nein hobelwurm stand Syrer das ist
der Code für heute keine Post ach so
aber nett schrunsenflug schrunsenflug
schrunsenflug schrunsenflug [Applaus]